who will be our next prime minister
tonight the country a step closer to the
answer as MPS Finally Revealed the final
two contenders to succeed Boris Johnson
Rishi sunak and Liz truss will be the
candidates going forward to a final
ballot of conservative party members and
with that the job of MPS done one of two
candidates who both served in Boris
Johnson's cabinet will be the next PM
this is going to be a battle of ideas
isn't it Rishi sunat's like steady as
you go you're the radical tax cutter
right I'm not complacent at all I am
going to be working very hard over the
next six weeks to put my case to
conservative party members what I
believe is that lowering taxes opening
up opportunities is going to help us
deliver the economic growth that Britain
needs and it's also going to help
deliver us the next election for all the
spinning here the supporting the selling
both Rishi Suna can is truss a largely
continuity candidates but their
positions on the economy and tax cuts
are far apart I've always said that I
want to be honest with the British
people about the challenges we face and
be responsible in dealing with them and
people know my track record I help get
this country through an incredibly
difficult period over the last couple of
years I made sure that we supported
those who needed our help at every step
with interventions like the furlough
that's what people can expect from me
going forward and at a time of challenge
I think we need someone who's got the
experience to do that one challenge done
but the next will be to convince the
conservative party membership and that's
a very different race how worried are
you about Liz truss in the terms of
sunac might have won the MPS but he's
got the the second part's harder for him
isn't it well we'll have to make the
case to our members I'm very confident
going forward we can do that having
spoken to a lot of party members I think
they recognize that he's probably better
placed to win a general election and
that will be a very very big part of the
the thinking of our members when they
cast a vote winning elections was
something this man did well any regrets
prime minister
do you want anyone but Rishi the
incumbent heading to pmqs one last time
in a final outing that was less about
him and more about his would-be
successes who between them have written
kierstormer's attack lines in recent
days the foreign secretary says we can't
go on with our current economic policy
the member for Portsmouth North bemoan
the fact that what we've been doing has
not been good enough
and the member for Saffron Walden
probably puts it best when she simply
asked why should the public trust us we
haven't exactly covered ourselves in
glory
their Future Leaders words
what message does it send when the
candidates be prime minister can't find
any find a single decent thing to say
about him about each other or their
recording government
and as they looked on the PM gave a
strong hint as to who he doesn't want to
stand in his shoes next praise in Liz
truss's tax cutting plans as he took aim
at rival Rishi sunak I want to use the
last few seconds Mr Speaker to give some
words of advice to uh to my successor
whoever he or she may be number one stay
close to the Americans stick up for the
ukrainians stick up for freedom and
democracy everywhere car taxes and
deregulate wherever you can to make this
the greatest place to live and invest
which it is
I love the treasury but remember that if
we'd always listened to the treasury we
wouldn't have built the M25 or the
channel tunnel focus focus on the road
ahead focus on the road ahead but always
remember to check the rear view mirror
the last few years have been the
greatest privilege of of my life and
it's true that I I helped to get the
biggest Tory majority for 40 years
at a huge realignment in UK politics
Mission largely accomplished
hasta la vista baby thank you
a stand Innovation and pats on the back
but this form of PM's body language
revealing what plenty of her colleagues
privately feel slow to stand and no
applause many backbenchers glad to see
the back of him MPS have made their
choice and now it falls to conservative
party members to decide whether Rishi
sunak or Liz truss will become our next
prime minister two heavyweights battling
it out with different economic Visions
for Britain sunac is steady as he goes
whereas Liz truss has a more radical
plan for tax cuts she is the favorite
for now amongst the party Grassroots but
there's still everything to play for and
it's far from Clear who will win out
what is clearer is it will be all out
War and the bigger question beyond all
of that is can either of these
politicians deliver the sort of majority
that Boris Johnson did back in 2019
one prime minister ousted and his party
deeply divided over who comes next a
summer of bitter infighting beckons for
a governing party now at Sea Beth Rigby
Sky News Westminster
and in just over two weeks time we'll
see those two candidates go head to head
right here on Sky News we'll have a live
televised debate as the bear continue
with their campaigns to become the next
leader of the conservative party and the
next prime minister the debate will be
hosted by K Burley and take place on
Thursday the 4th of August at 8 00 pm